[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
in 2005 we were nearing the end of a
console generation the Xbox 360 was on
store shelves Nintendo was prepping for
the Wii and Sony was approaching the
launch of the PlayStation 3 and although
the ps2 was technically on its way out
its best days were still ahead of it god
of war and its sequel had yet to grace
the platform as did Okami bully Tekken 5
Kingdom Hearts 2 and one of my personal
favorites timesplitters future perfect
and for a cult following that had waited
four years to see the follow up to 2001
s eco the wait would soon be over in
October of 2005 developer team eco
released Shadow of the Colossus a game
that even early on was an obvious
masterpiece
Colossus took the lonely surreal
artistry of team egos previous work and
amplified it tenfold it challenged our
assumptions about open worlds level
design and puzzle solving it made us
rethink what boss fights could be but on
an even higher level what they could
mean if you haven't played Shadow of the
Colossus chances are you've still heard
of it and if you have played it chances
are you won't forget about it anytime
soon with its recent ps4 remake almost
thirteen years after its first
appearance Shadow of the Colossus is
somehow still relevant maybe more than
that it's still transcendent for game to
hold up that long in a medium known for
its fleeting moments is no small feat
whether you're experiencing again or
playing it for the first time now is a
perfect moment to re-examine what makes
Shadow of the Colossus a game worth
learning from Shadow the Colossus has a
simple setup our protagonist wanderer
arrives in the Forbidden Lands on his
horse agro carrying the girl mono intent
on resurrecting her with a power rumor
to sleep here an omnipresent spirit
named doorman tells wander the rumors
are true so long as he can slay sixteen
powerful colossi strewn throughout the
wilderness that's almost the entire plot
almost
from there Colossus seems
straightforward you raise your magical
sword to the Sun follow its beam of
light and kill the Colossus resting at
that location each of the beasts dark
energy then snakes out from its corpse
and into wanders body warping him back
to the starting trine exploding the
stone idols that line the wall doorman
hints at the location of the next
Colossus and you're off to repeat the
same process of course this is the most
reductive possible explanation of the
game I haven't mentioned many things
first off these colossi are the only
enemies in the game despite being an
open-world the Forbidden Lands aren't
lined with filler content on your way to
the first boss it feels weirdly quiet on
your way to the second it feels
downright eerie there are no NPCs
waypoints or side quests aside from
upgrades in the form of stamina boosting
lizards and health improving fruit there
are no other collectibles to speak of in
2005 this minimalist approach made
colossus an anomaly the recent grand
theft auto san andreas and mercenaries
playground of destruction relied on
worlds packed to the brim with things to
do people to kill and missions to
complete the upcoming Elder Scrolls for
oblivion perhaps more than any other
game to date was built on this idea
today developers have spent more than a
decade making open-world titles
littering them with objective markers
and quest icons AI companions and
pointless collectables we played so many
of them that we forgot what made open
worlds great to begin with in 2005
Shadow the Colossus felt like a warning
today it feels almost like a lament
games used to be open-world for a reason
aside from a few standout titles many
have lost sight of them in 2017 The
Legend of Zelda breath of the wild
released and much like Shadow of the
Colossus reminded me why I love
open-world games it captures the pure
joy of exploration and uses its open
environment as a core design principle
its sprawling environment isn't tacked
on as an additional feature but it fuels
its every mechanic
[Music]
[Applause]
the similarities between shadow the
Colossus and Zelda don't end there
from Ito await a renowned creative
director from team eco said that
Colossus was his riff on a Zelda game in
an interview with insert credit in 2005
who ate a set of the game's colossi
they're not bosses they're more like
inverted Zelda dungeons after only the
first giant you kill you see what he
means it's not just about identifying
the creatures weak spots and striking
him where it hurts but also figuring out
how to get to those spots there's often
environmental puzzle solving - as you
expose this Giants weak stomach or
distract this one from one angle before
assaulting it from another you start to
realize that these colossi don't just
fill the traditional role of the boss
fight but also the trials you face to
get to that boss fight instead of locked
doors and enemies in your way there is
only the Goliath and anything between
your sword and it's vulnerable organs
permeating all of this is a melancholic
soundtrack
the music swells with sad crescendos
during Colossus battles amplifying as
the creatures fall to the ground with
their final whimpers although many of
the colossi are aggressive it's hard not
to feel guilty as they collapse they
have the animations of humans or
domestic pets in the final moments
before their death and the game makes
sure to send them off with a somber
soundtrack of course the guilt you feel
upon killing one Colossus is nothing
compared to what's coming if you've been
Shadow of the Colossus you know what I'm
talking about if you haven't I'll give
one more spoiler warning and suggest you
go play it now come back and finish this
video Colossus is known for having one
of the better endings to a video game
for a reason the entirety of Shadow of
the Colossus draws on myths legends and
fables the theme of resurrection and the
punishment for defying fate runs rampant
throughout there are parallels to the
Greek story of Orpheus and Eurydice in
which Orpheus enters the underworld to
retrieve his partner of course each of
the games battles is also a reenactment
of the famous underdog story of David's
fight against the Goliath but among
other biblical references in shadow the
Colossus there's also that of doorman
the omniscient being that's guiding you
to each Colossus years ago observant
players noticed that when spelled
backwards store man's name was Nimrod
despite the insulting modern
connotations Nimrod was a biblical king
that came to be known as a villain and
upon dying his corpse was cut up and
scattered across vast distances for
Shadow the colossus veterans this should
ring a very loud bell after the 12th
colossus Falls one of the game's few
cutscenes triggers a band of men enters
the Forbidden Lands approaching the
shrine you've been returning to there in
a rush to stop something or someone
after killing the 16th and final
Colossus you discover that someone is
you like the clue and his name might
suggest doorman is an evil entity he was
killed long ago his energy scatter to
prevent him from returning each part of
his soul was attached to a creature
sixteen different creatures to be exact
by killing each of the colossi you've
been helping to rebuild doorman from
scratch you've been upon the whole time
committing evil deeds for an evil being
taking 16 lives in the hole
of bringing back one suddenly it all
makes sense maybe T Nico left the fields
empty the forests quiet the lakes calm
and devoid of bad guys because you are
in fact the bad guy team eco drives this
point home by making you a colossus
yourself albeit a much more sinister one
than the ones you've been butchering you
are doorman reincarnate and there is
nothing beautiful about you look back at
the 13th colossus the one that for me
embodies much of what makes this game a
classic this serpent-like sand creature
requires mastery of archery horse riding
stamina management and spatial awareness
in order to take down but more than that
if you pay attention it hints at what's
really going on because it doesn't once
fight back even as you're stabbing it
beneath its stony dorsal fins weakening
it to the point of exhaustion it keeps
just wandering the desert
that's all it wants to do several other
colossi follow suit while some of them
are aggressive once you enter their turf
others won't attack until provoked
you're coming into their home and
killing them for reasons you don't fully
understand because you never bothered to
question what you're doing there are a
handful of other games that use an end
game twists making you question your
actions up to that point I won't spoil
them out of the blue here but you can
probably think of one major 2007 title
that does something pretty similar but
even so I think Shadow the Colossus has
one of the more affecting stories of any
game I've played it conveys guilt regret
and sorrow emotions that I don't seek
out in everyday life but they're
powerful nonetheless that a videogame
could make me genuinely sorry for the
things I had killed was at the time
almost unheard of today it's etched into
my memory if the act of replaying shadow
the Colossus on ps4 isn't enough to
cement it as a masterpiece in your mind
look to other games in recent years
destiny bosses require little more than
a restless trigger finger Ubisoft has
given us open-world games with content
for contents sake for the better part of
a decade even the very recent Monster
Hunter World a game I love and I'm
playing at every single chance I get
encourages us to hunt creatures kill
them
and then just wear them as trophies much
like it was a reaction to other video
games in 2005 Shadow the Colossus still
feels monumental today and with its
recent remake I'm hoping more people pay
attention from here on out
[Music]
you